today I am the
immigration organizer here for my family vote if
we try to work a lot with the
immigrant community or when there are
events like this we try to go to the
community and talk to them that is very
important that we also come to talk
to the students because  sometimes you
don't know so much what is happening either
but not so much about what are the things that they
can do more and what is happening and they
want to sometimes they want to know more and they
don't know where to get that information right
now it is very important that we celebrate
all things  what
immigrants do how they work things they
do for our community and also
making sure that we are fighting for
that is what they still occupy right now in
this very important moment that we are
fighting for citizenship that they
spend everything in congress we have to
celebrate but there is  You have to recognize that there is a
lot of work to do and that you have to
fight for citizenship now because
even if you are not an immigrant you have  It is a
connection to someone who, if they are an immigrant,
could be your parents, well, your friends
could be your neighbor, someone you
work with in Lincoln, that you go to school
and
all the people need help and need to
be celebrated if someone has been
impacted on you, there is a  80 that if they are not
immigrants they themselves have a connection
to someone who is a
Haitian immigrant denver game I am united
with immigrants because they all help
our two united to this community and we
must celebrate them